I want to knock on front
[Music]
hi Lexi
can I go up there
what do you mean that's all you're gonna
tell me
what is she under arrest for
18 thank you that's not what that is
what is she under arrest
no I'm not bringing her out here yet let
me know when she's under arrested
regardless
or what for what
for what are you okay
with evidence tampering with evidence
at the hospital
give me a minute
okay
I have a right to see a warrant it
doesn't matter if she's over the age of
18. this is my house you have a right
you have to show me that part
even if she's under arrest
hey I have I have the detectives here um
they want to arrest my daughter they're
saying um they have a warrant but they
can't show me a run for her arrest
well we'll get to well there I'll give
you a coffee she gets her coffee
that's a curve
it's an arrest warrant for her
I want to see their wrists worn and what
will that prove
this is over I'm coming for the police
department in the hospital I am yes
ma'am
foreign
[Music]
okay
okay so I guess I'm going to
do it
I could respond for obstruction
foreign
[Applause]
this job
it really is and we understand but we
have to do our jobs too okay
just bring her out you can be with her
the entire time okay do you know where
the public safety complex is 3300 West
Main you can follow us over there
[Applause]
as soon as we I released
when can I get like her bond what that
set up by the judge is Spanish to judge
Foster he should be doing it if it's
after three he'll be doing it in the
morning
go on the back all right
all right
what's your name Lexi okay okay so
that's for your social
she don't even know it
Alexa do you know your date of birth yes
okay
yeah do you have to walk all the way
over there can you bring your car up
here
I'll go get it
Alexa are you okay with your mom getting
your control complaint when we get to
the Detention Center it has your
personal information
do you want are you okay with your
mother getting the criminal complaint it
has your personal identifying
information on it serial number eight of
us yes are you okay yes okay
after surgery first then your mom can
get it okay okay
he's gonna move his unit around
no medications anything you take while
you're in there
she has still been um like bleeding so I
don't know if she needs do you have any
they do I don't know if they have
tampons
okay okay but I'm pretty sure if you
take your own
Gucci do you want to grab something can
she grab some of that real quick
go ahead
just making sure you're doing it okay
and it's nothing sharp no flammables
nothing sharp okay
okay they're gonna check it when you get
over there okay okay
same thing okay we're gonna check all
that when you get over there okay
I'm going up there right now too okay
all right what's in there personal pads
there's no pads yeah she needs she needs
them
3200 West Main Street the public safety
complex if you just go through the front
door you know where we first spoke in
the records
yeah
if you just go over there
is there any four no okay I'll meet her
in the front okay I'll get with him and
do all staff go to dispatch
relay the rest
I'll be headed your way for the Relay
shortly
[Applause]
all right
let's see here's your final complaint
while I want to ask you before I go to
your mom are you okay with her getting
that information serial number all that
okay
would you like me would you want to keep
this to read or would you want to give
this to your mom or would you want her
to have a copy
um
okay you don't want to read it
okay all right the next one
is a search warrant for your person okay
this is for you
your date of birth your social security
number I'm going to be searching your
person what I'm going to be doing is
getting a vehicle swap sufficient for
Laboratory Testing okay this is both
yours keep
okay
I'll make a copy so you can read it and
your mom can get one okay have you ever
been to the doctor's office
no just in your life
okay you know when they do a swallow
your mouth see if you have a cold
something like that yeah that's all I'm
gonna be doing all I need you to do is
open your mouth
why I don't like your yawning I'm just
gonna touch the inside of your mouth
with a swab with a con swab that's all I
need okay it's painless there's nothing
else added to it it's just cotton okay
[Applause]
can you open your mouth for me okay
all right almost done
all right
now I'm just gonna do one more pair okay
your feet
okay one more time okay you want to do
the other side of your mouth
all right that's it
you don't want to read them
oh
right here three two one
face your whole body this way looking
forward you freaking Define the back the
back
now face the other direction
pull your hair back a little bit too
you guys want to sign everyone
right there right there one
right there one right by side yes okay
no no I'll give you a copy for years
this one that says they're gonna travel
on our top or otherwise let's finish
let me finish reading that sir I'm sorry
I'm sorry let me go that's it and I'll
get you a copy for you
[Applause]
foreign
sir
and we did it approximately 4 30 PM
let's get another one don't take my pen
and this is just showing you this goes
with this one I'm just showing you I got
two pairs of people so I was fishing for
lab testing okay there's a two we got
finished okay you can we can make you a
copy it's fine you can just give it to
my mom you so both all of it
um sure okay
okay if you want a copy
you can get it from him or if I'm here
you can get it from me okay